[Music]
[Music]
what was the last godzilla before most
of us titanus gojira came to be well the
fastest answer would obviously be
godzilla from final wars from 2004 but
that is wrong for a few minutes of
screen time godzilla was seen in live
action in a relatively unknown touhou
movie called always sunset on 3rd street
so what is godzilla 2007
well he is a figment of a writer's
imagination in the movie but at the same
time like the other godzilla cameo such
as snow godzilla ready player 1 mega
godzilla and others as well this one too
deserves an analysis video
so let's get to it
let's talk a little bit about the movie
that showcased this godzilla's cameo
what is the movie always sunset on third
street about
well it's about a man named chagawa who
is a writer and a story revolves around
him and his sword junosuke as well as a
cousin of his a little kid named mika
who was the daughter of a rich
businessman called suzuki so to obtain a
decent living lifestyle to show hiromi
that he has become a better man chagawa
begins to write a literary piece
to win the akutagawa prize a dream that
he had given up a long time ago
well godzilla makes a cameo appearance
as a character in one of chigawa stories
in the touhou film always
in the scenario the writer chigawa
imagined godzilla attacking tokyo
destroying suzuki's auto business and
even destroying tokyo tower with his
atomic breath much to suzuki's anger
suzuki then accused gosel of destroying
his company and godzilla retaliated with
a roar however chigawa was interrupted
by a small kid named junosuke his ward
who informed him that godzilla was
already a real figure and could not be
utilized in the novel prompting the
author to begin over
well the gmk goji was the direct
inspiration for the third straight
godzilla design which was based on
sculptor shunsuke nua's garage kit of
the gmk goji
he has a similar appearance to the jmk
goji with white dorsal plates nails and
eyes those white eyes his legs are
widely separated and he has a big neck
and a lengthy tail with a few dorsal
plates going around the top of his back
godzilla has a limited amount of
fang-like teeth a short tongue and an
overbite that yamazaki compared to a
dog's bite he slumped over from his
shoulders down and what's godzilla's
size in this movie well it looks to be
around 60 meters or 200 feet tall the
same as the one from gmk
godzilla's raw from the millennium
series as well as the rose from the
tri-star godzilla are reused in 3rd
street gaza which makes his sound kind
of a hybrid between the american and
japanese gojis
godzilla also has his iconic power the
atomic breath
well in he used it to slice the tokyo
tower in half with a single blast of his
blue breath
not just that but this goji is also
powerful in terms of brute strength as
he always is it will see that godzilla
used his tail to destroy a tiny
neighborhood with a single swipe
and many other neighborhoods too just by
walking over them
so the question why was it forgotten why
was godzilla 2007 overlooked i'm pretty
sure there are a lot of fans that know
of his existence but there are also
millions of others who have absolutely
no idea about him who are absolutely
unawares about it
well to put it simply it is that
godzilla's cameo in this movie was just
a small part
and that his character just vanished
after that even though it's a touhou
movie even though the initial scene of
godzilla causing destruction in mayhem
was enticing to look at
but that was about it for the king of
the monsters in this movie
and hence there was not even a secondary
plotline as in the case of cameos like
ready player ones mechagodzilla ancient
gunsons snow godzilla
that was all we got about him so that's
why
but then again let's look at him one
more time before forgetting he exists
again
he is 60 meters or 200 feet tall
and has white eyes like gmk godzilla as
well as a grayish green skin
and he has an atomic breath
so that's all
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video
and with that we come to the end of it
so do hit that like button for support
and subscribe as well to be a part of
the mind cue family
but most of all smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one
take care fam